[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you have a museum-quality work of
art on your court you just maintain
that's basically cherish the space
differently
when I find the court that needs a
little extra love you only collaborate
with the community to turn parking lot
into a place that's really exciting for
you to come out and play basketball
together
[Music]
we are designing a basketball team hip
is special because like the culture of
it is diverse just not like every other
school it wasn't even a basketball court
here was a parking lot and I like how
you guys making it super excited to be
working with the uncle drew movie I
think I've always wanted to play to
paint a basketball court kids getting
involved painting and yeah I mean it's
an amazing opportunity basically our
goal is to ensure that all communities
have a safe and inviting place to play
outdoor basketball I'll find an artist
to design something special and unique
to go down that court surface project
back for came out today for the
basketball court allow the kids to know
that wherever they are at even if it's
an inner-city we're still able to have
something nice with them this is very
important it's very beautiful I love it
thank you all you everybody we work
really hard to make sure that our
students are feel safe here and are
welcomed here but make sure that like we
have a very welcoming and positive
environment inside our walls I feel
happy and cared for they care about what
our school looks like because if we're
in like a I don't know area our school
is going to be
are you excited I still can't hear you
[Music]
[Applause]
I didn't love you the most beautiful
Court I've done they've really turned
out to it and I couldn't be happier the
kids was outstanding the ground looks
wonderful and it's all brought to you by
Lionsgate absolute and Gleason report
and we are